iPhone 15 versus 15 Pro the pro model is
the much better choice this year right
well it's actually not that simple
because this year Apple made the regular
15 a very compelling upgrade but as for
the 15 Pro not so much you probably know
that this smaller pro model didn't get
the new 5x telephoto camera like we got
on the pro Max but you likely don't know
that it's actually missing more upgrades
than just that but wait this video is
actually about the regular 15 versus the
15 Pro after 2 weeks of use and there's
a lot more to talk about in terms of the
real differences that you're going to
experience on a daily basis so let's get
started first off we've got to talk
about the design differences this year
with both of them coming with the really
nice curved edges which feel so much
more comfortable in the hands and as far
as the new titanium frame on the pro
model it actually feels more similar to
the regular aluminum chassis than ever
before but keep in mind that it's grade
five titanium so it's going to be
stronger and more resistant to dents and
scuffs but unlike the titanium it
actually seems to have a sort of Sheen
or shine to it which looks really nice
but after 2 weeks I've noticed so many
more fingerprints on the Titanium Pro
which have honestly gotten really
annoying now one major upgrade for the
regular 15 is that for the the first
time in years it actually looks more
premium and pro than ever before thanks
to a combination of three design
elements on top of the similarities in
the frames finish number one is the fact
that Apple finally gave the regular 15's
a matte textured back which looks and
feels so much more premium greatly
reducing fingerprints on the back glass
number two is actually the new subtle
selection of colors which looks a whole
a lot more premium compared to the very
saturated almost toight colors of the
past it now just looks more clean and
expensive overall and number three is of
course the fact that Apple finally
removed the notch on the regular 15 and
the displays now look basically
identical from the front with the
premium Dynamic Island feature so you
can hardly tell them apart anymore and
for those reasons the regular 15s look
more Pro than ever before however
that's just the surface level because if
you look a lot more closely you're going
to notice a huge difference in display
bezel size which to me is a big deal
after 2 weeks having a more immersive
display on the pro it just looks so much
more premium but then when we start
talking about the display quality itself
Apple for some reason gave the regular
15s basically the same display panel as
on the pros with up to the same crazy
2,000 nits of brightness which I wasn't
expecting Apple to do at all so you're
really getting so much more value this
year on the regular 15 and then on the
other hand disappointingly the display
has not changed at all on the 15 Pro
since it's already quite good especially
since it supports 120hz promotion
display technology which makes the
display look super smooth when browsing
through the web and using apps
especially since it supports 120 FPS
gaming but regardless of all of that
we're starting to see a trend where the
iPhone 15 is getting a bunch of really
nice new upgrades while the 15 Pro isn't
really getting much changes at all so
with that said why would people even buy
the pro model to begin with well there
are actually some reasons that are
really quite convincing including the
new chip and the cameras but regardless
of whether you buy the 15 or the 15 Pro
you're definitely going to need a good
case like the ultra hybrid smag from our
sponsor span it's very durable while
coming with a kickstand for browsing or
watching movies that's now fully flush
with the back so you get full Mac safe
support for charging and accessories
like their Valentina Three Card Wallet
which holds on incredibly well due to
the grippy texture on the back they also
have their easy fit screen protector
which has by far the easiest
installation I've ever seen with its
convenient alignment case and they've
even got their easy fit optic Pro real
glass camera lens protector which is
just as easy to install and looks really
cool with camera spec details but my
personal favorite is their tear down
case with this awesome 3D component
design which you can couple with their
Arc field Max safe wireless charger with
a built-in kickstand for watching videos
or standby mode and you can order all of
these amazing span products today by
using the links in the description below
now getting back to the 15 vers 15 Pro
conversation are people buying the pro
model because of the USBC Port that's 20
times faster than the one in the regular
15 well probably not because most people
are just using airdrop is it because the
speakers got much better this year on
the 15 Pro actually no the speaker
quality is the same on both the 15 and
15 Pro while this year only the 15 plus
and 15 Pro Max models got a big upgrade
in terms of speaker quality is it
because of the action button that's
exclusive to the Pro Models maybe but
it's mostly a fun new feature that
really gives you a sense of freedom on
the iPhone which we haven't felt in
years allowing you to do actually useful
things if you know what you're doing but
no it's honestly not a deal breaker it's
more of a fun little bonus the main two
reasons are the a17 pro chip and what
comes with that as well as the cameras
so let's jump right into it yes the a16
chip is already fast but the A7 Pro is
undoubtedly faster and I know you're
going to say that it literally doesn't
make a difference in the real world but
it does first of all the Pro Models get
8 GB of RAM compared to six on the
regular 15s which is going to make the
phone a bit more responsive in general
especially when multitasking it's also
going to help keep keep your apps open
for longer without resetting them in the
background to free up more RAM so that's
always a plus the A7 Pro also has a
bunch of architectural changes to all of
the cores including the CPU having wider
data decoders and a bunch of other
changes as well as a new metal Shader
architecture pipeline for the GPU and
don't forget that the neural engine is
basically two times faster which is
going to help with everything including
gaming General performance and camera
software processing as well and last but
not least we have the upgraded GPU which
now includes Hardware raate tracing and
metal effects support which means that
with the 15 Pro you'll have exclusive
access to a bunch of real AAA games
starting with the four that Apple
recently revealed at their event while
you won't even be able to install them
on the regular 15 and not only that but
metal effect support is already here in
games like ginch and impact greatly
reducing the power usage and Heat
leading to a better gaming experience
with really great quality and even
without all of that just the fact that
the A7 Pro's GPU now has six cores to
split the performance load between is
actually going to lead to lower clock
speeds across the board to achieve the
same FPS as with five cores which will
use less power than the 816 if there's
an FPS cap like 60 FPS so basically
buying the 15 Pro will really future
proof your device as more and more games
and apps come out and now let's get into
the cameras and I've got admit that the
regular 15s got a killer upgrade this
year with the new 48 megapixel camera
sensor which now allows for insanely
high quality 48 megap Hy photos as well
as the default new 24 megapix photo
output for regular photos and also
portraits which is awesome even better
that new 48 megapixel camera sensor
means that you now get a new 2x camera
button which actually has incredible
quality because it crops into the middle
of the sensor and applies software
Corrections before you take the photo to
greatly improve the quality and also
allow for 2x portrait shots which was
the biggest issue with previous regular
models not having that and yes the new
regular 15s also get the smart HDR 5
upgrade which has been incredible for
dynamic range improvements so this is
probably the biggest camera upgrade on
the regular iPhones in years however the
iPhone 15 Pro is still better because
the actual 48 megapixel sensor is bigger
so low light is going to be better and
we of course have the 3x telephoto lens
for much much better Zoom photos and for
Unique 3x portraits which look great and
then of course there's the 15 Pro Max
with the 5x lens which is on a whole
another level so in the real world after
about 2 weeks of use I've really got to
hand it to the 15 Pro for the extra
freedom and flexibility that you get
with that additional 3x lens and the
camera improvements so for that reason
and for the a17 pro chip as well as all
the other differences I mentioned it's
probably worth spending the extra $200
for the 15 Pro however since this is the
best regular iPhone upgrade in years I
wouldn't say you'd be wrong for choosing
the 15 instead if you're on a budget
I've actually recommended the regular 15
to some family members already because
it's just so solid of an upgrade so my
recommendation this year is just to
follow your budget and you're going to
be a happy camper unless you're a gamer
in that case you definitely want the A7
Pro chip in the 15 Pro so hopefully this
video was helpful and if if you enjoyed
it definitely subscribe above and check
out the span products down in the
description below thanks for watching
and definitely check out one of those
two videos right over there I'll see you
in the next
[Music]
one